with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you can get to
them all so if you didn't see AI hub the
one place for everything ai then stay
tuned because here's the rewind the AI
universe is expanding which means you
can get more creative with it than ever
before and the possibilities are endless
unfortunately it might feel like the
things you need to learn to get going
are endless too the space has grown huge
messy and daunting so what if you could
step into a tidy parallel a tight
universe that combines everything you
need to make your experience with
building AI magical welcome to AI hub
the vision behind Google clouds AI hub
is to give you a 10x force multiplier by
taking the confusion repetition and
wheel reinvention right out of your work
AI hub brings together a number of
managed services to make your lives
easier and because AI is a team sport
AI hub is designed with skills diversity
in mind and focuses on making it easy to
do what you do best and then share your
work with colleagues who love the other
parts it's for the data scientist who
wants to work on the cutting edge
without the painful slow going every
time you want to try something new
it's for the app developer looking for
that familiar pattern of discovery
without getting dunked in the
mathematical nitty-gritty and it's for
the machine learning production engineer
who keeps getting asked why the model
took three weeks to build but 10 months
to put into production hint production
used to be hard it's for the person who
loves point-and-click and a great UI and
for the person who likes direct command
line access whoever you are if you build
with AI it's for you ai hub isn't just a
ski-lift for your machine learning
chores it's the whole resort and as a
result the talk is quite frankly unser
Mirai Zabaleen credible demos and you'll
definitely want to experience them but
here's a small taste a iHub features
instant vm and jupiter notebook setup
a brain friendly brilliantly searchable
repository of code to get you started
collaboration tools extra transfer
learning support and cube flow faring to
jumpstart your move to production with
raid go end-to-end pipeline templates
and broken down components to help you
mix and match instead of reinventing
that wheel oh and don't forget access to
tf-x that's tensorflow
extended google's recently open sourced
tailor-made production machine learning
pipeline with advanced mobile analytics
capabilities that accelerate your
development process helping you iterate
in a smarter direction to launch your
awesome system faster this is the power
to build quickly it's the joy of
collaborating without having to take
everything on your own shoulders and
it's the beauty of enjoying a magical
user experience as an AI builder if
you'd like to see the full talk check
out the link in the description below
and don't forget to subscribe to the
cloud YouTube channel for more great
next rewind content thanks for watching
[Music]